[Music]
all right let's go to john in greenville
north carolina what's up brother john
how are we doing
hey thanks for taking my call you got it
man thanks for calling what's up so i'm
calling because i was listening to your
show a little while ago when you were
talking about
a husband that was checked out and i
just really resonated with me
that i feel like that is
definitely where i'm at and that's what
my wife
has complained about as well
why are you checked out man
well see in my opinion i'm not
because i feel like i've been trying
and
my attempts are never
good enough for it to count or
not fast enough there's a million
reasons but so she's telling you that
you're checked out you don't think you
are
[Music]
the crutch okay
is she is she
is she bonkers or she lying or is she
right
you know
exactly that side meant she's right okay
so why are you checked out
so
it's just i don't i don't feel like i'm
ever getting it right so
i mean if i try and do like she wants to
go out i'll plan a date and then
there's some element she'll
pick up on that i missed or it could
have been better and
parks on that one thing and then it
just feels like my attempts aren't going
anywhere so words words like always and
never those are exaggeration and drama
words and they often come up in
relationships and they're just drama so
let's drill down they're never totally
true it's never always or never whatever
so what are a couple of things in your
house that you do really well
so
to be honest right now we're actually
separated
hey
fun idea lead with that next time dude
lead with that okay so before you got
separated what were some things that you
did right
so
i was doing
wait hold on why are you separated
because we
try to trial separation and
i kind of lied about some things
basically
it started out i was going to school
and i was the one that lied
about
still being in school and i wasn't
okay
and i came
clean and then
i lost some money and didn't
come clean
immediately with it
okay
did you call did you call in a previous
show
no i did not but i know once i said that
i've heard these themes before okay
so you told your wife you were in school
what'd you do with the money
i was actually trading
trading stocks yes and you lost because
everyone loses money when they do that
yes and then
then you try to get it back
yeah and it didn't work yeah
and then
i hit it for a while before i told my
wife and
what else were you hiding
nothing anymore that was it
you weren't seeing somebody else
no
john
i was not all right
i'll trust you
and so you hid the money you hid this
and then you lied about it and then what
i went to therapy and it just didn't you
don't need to go to therapy if you just
are someone who didn't tell the truth
why'd y'all go to therapy
so to get try to get her
trust back
so therapy was just a move it was like
an roi for you
like i'll do these three things and then
it'll be all all good
that's what i was hoping for sure yeah
did you learn anything about yourself in
therapy
yes what'd you learn definitely
a lot of it
i'm just
very insecure in general and that's
okay a lot of the reason i hide things
that don't come clean
um
i don't know i just had a lot of people
leave in my life so i always have that
fear
like coming clean
is going to push people away or they're
going to say
buzz too much i'm not i'm out
and so you hold it all in you keep
secrets and you don't tell the truth
which
which guarantees they're going to move
away right
yes yeah
so what what ultimately boiled up and
led to the separation
basically i mean she just didn't trust
me like it
a lot of little things
do you lie about a lot of stuff
no okay like the last lie i told
i asked a friend to pick my son up from
daycare because i was running late
and
they told my wife before i did
and so
and i'm talking like an hour
but you didn't tell your wife that you
needed someone to pick up your son
well i did
but she already knew about it
so
so why don't you trust her why don't you
trust your wife
what about her as untrustworthy
uh nothing anymore
really i
i think a lot of what's going on now is
i just didn't see the
need to tell her any earlier because i
was
gonna see her and that's when i saw her
i told her
so how can i help you today man
so
i don't know
because my therapist have kind of run
out of ideas to
help with this is it is there something
you can suggest or is it what do you
want to help with i don't i don't
understand what like when you when you
first called i thought man you can't get
anything right at your house and you
want some help with
you know being engaged at home but you
don't even live there anymore
and then turns out there was some big
secrets and some big deception
um financial infidelities that my buddy
dave calls it um
so i don't know what you i don't know
what you're looking for
nothing you've told me so far would
suggest you need therapy in any way
maybe i'm missing something it sounds
like you may need to make some firm life
commitments and then go after it
yeah i guess
what do you mean am i missing something
yeah i don't know
i don't know i guess i'm kind of in this
stuck funk where i don't know
what to do next either because
is your marriage over
[Applause]
i don't know i mean i i guess that's the
fear i fear that it is
you would know is it over or not
do you have a plan to get back together
are you all talking are you still being
honest with her are you gonna get back
together or what
you know whether it's over or not
i want to but she doesn't see
how it's gonna happen or
okay
so i didn't ask if are you trying to end
the marriage i'm asking you is it over
she told you this is over
so yeah i guess it is has she filed on
you
no is she going to
she i don't think so i haven't said that
she is let's take a let's take a pause
on that conversation
john
what
do you
want
with your life
with you with your relationship with
your friends answer that question what
just comes to mind what do you want
well i'd like to get back with her no no
no no no what do you want
that's a thing that's like a i just want
this i want a couch beneath that what do
you want your life to be dude
i've sat with single moms
and very few people can answer that
question
like what do you want
i i don't really know i guess
and so
no therapist will be able to help you
because you don't know where you're
going you keep going to
map makers and
gps app developers
to get you wherever it is you want to go
and you don't know where you want to go
and
you keep going into a hospital for
surgery and they don't know what you
want to do they don't know what to
operate on
and so a question for you the one magic
question in your life
john how old are you
37 37 you get one
one life
and maybe what you're 40 done 50 done
let's say 40. yeah you get one you got
60 left
what do you want
do you want peace do you want happiness
do you want to laugh a whole bunch do
you want to make millions of dollars
what do you want
all the above sounds great okay pick one
like what do you want
i would say happiness is number one
thing okay let's drill down what is
happy just give me two or three pictures
of happy what makes you happy what
brings you joy
taking my son out
um doing what in the time
uh going to the pool
am i doing that together
uh what else what's another picture of
something that brings you joy
i love tinkering with things okay like
building things uh
and then
i guess hanging out with friends i don't
even care what just being around people
all right
so
the conversation you got to have with
john is
i want to build a life where i'm
surrounded by people i love
i want to have a life where i get to
spend a lot of one-on-one time with my
son
doing things that don't involve my phone
doing things with us
throwing each other around a pool and
laughing and carrying on
and maybe
i want to build a life
with this woman that i had started a
relationship with that i was married to
we have kids together
and i screwed it up and i'm gonna start
there
because right now you're in response
mode you're in defense mode
think about a basketball team that never
shoots the ball all they do is play
defense and every time you
get a turnover you just roll it back to
the other team
because you don't even know how to shoot
you know where the basket is
yeah
and so
right now you're trying to win her back
or what are the four things i need to do
to make her
trust me again
and if there's any hope of salvaging
this relationship it's you taking her
out one more time and sitting down and
saying
oh my i was wrong
now i didn't get it before i was trying
to do things to make you like me or i
was trying to do enough so that you
wouldn't
nag me or complain
and i missed it
what i should have been doing
is being with you and loving you and
that other crap dishwasher stuff takes
care of itself you just do the dishes
because
it honors somebody that you love and you
want their life to be better and easier
and hopefully they are that's reciprocal
otherwise it gets into a contest of i
want you to take me out well then i'm
going to plan an outing well that outing
wasn't good enough well then the next
then you get into this it's a
competition it's a game
it's a waste of your life
love isn't a tennis match or a soccer
game man
am i right am i on to something
oh yeah definitely
okay
so remember this behavior is a language
and you people could talk all they want
i don't care what they're saying i want
to see how you treat people i want to
see how you interact with somebody how
you love somebody
how you walk home and say hey how can i
honor you today
that's different then i did the dishes
right
right and then you've got to be honest
with john you've got to be honest and
say here's where i want to go
and then a counselor or a coach
can help you get wherever it is you want
to go
but you got to choose brother to i don't
want
a
life of me
i want my life to be wheels off
i can tell you in my own life it was i
want to make this much money and i want
to have this job title i was that
specific and i realized what an
obnoxious
waste of my one tiny
little bitty precious life
i then changed it to dude i want to be
surrounded by people that i love
i want to do work that matters
to me and to the people that um are
involved in it
and i have a skill of sitting with
people when the wheels are falling off
their life and i'm gonna do that whether
i'm working at burger king or whether
i'm on the radio whether i'm a counselor
wherever that happens to be i'm gonna
sit with hurting people and then
strangely
oh by the way i'm gonna work real real
real hard real early in the morning
until real late at night for a day after
week after month after year and then
what you'll find is when those things
line up money takes care of itself and
titles take care of themself
but you gotta decide where you're going
first
and what you're doing john is trying to
get everybody else to tell you what your
life needs to look like and that's a
recipe for
depression that's a recipe for a black
hole like an energy and joy suck of just
a bottomless pit of yeah
because nobody can fill that hole only
you can
so you set it
you want to be surrounded by people you
love you want that woman to love you and
you want to love her and and and
start with that one precious question my
brother what do you want and then
go
get it